is it possible that maybe Trump's just  not quite as popular as you think he is  and he just lost David here's your  problem here's your problem tell me the  problem and all of you out there I went  on Jimmy Kimmel and Jimmy Kimmel asked  me Mike if this was reversed would you  still be selling in the alarm if your  friend Donald Trump did not win yeah and  if you remember I said absolutely I  would but I don't believe Martian and  post and political came to Minnesota and  questioned everyone in my town it seemed  like would Mike really do that and they  said absolutely he would I have a moral  compass it doesn't matter who won or  lost